second we have 19 trillion dollars in
debt we have people out of work we have
Isis and al-qaeda attacking us and we're
talking about fantasy football leave it
to chris Christie of all people to put
last night's Republican presidential
debate in perspective by acclamation The
Biggest Loser in the CNBC hosted shout
fast with CNBC itself whether it was the
amateur hour pregame show or moderators
making unsolicited confessions about
their own student loan debt and I had a
lot of student loans when I got out to
or pointed questions about the odd views
of former hewlett-packard executives not
named Carly Fiorina but just when you
thought the latest gotcha was a bridge
too far there came along blundering
Republicans like Jeb Bush showing just
why the GOP has become an unreliable
advocate in the cause of limited
government yes even for fantasy football
effectively it's day trading without any
regulation at all and when you have
insider information which apparently has
been the case where people use that
information use big data to try to take
advantage of it there has to be some
regulation it despite all their talk
about freedom Republicans are still
deeply conflicted when it comes to what
people do in the privacy of their own
homes for instance Ohio Governor John
Kasich has bizarre ideas about
legalizing marijuana sending mixed
signals to kids about drugs as a
disaster drugs is one of the greatest
scourge in this country I spent five
years of my administration working with
my team to do a whole sort of things to
try to rein in the problem and yet
somehow they're still managed to be
substantial discussion about fiscal and
regulatory issues that actually matter
Carly Fiorina made some important points
about the corrupting nexus between
business and government crony capitalism
is alive and well and has been so in
Washington DC for decades what's crony
capitalism crony capitalism is what
happens when government gets so big and
so powerful that only the big and the
powerful can handle it Rand Paul brought
some adult math to the table the main
problem with Medicare right now is that
the average person pays in taxes over
their whole lifetime about a hundred
but the average person takes out about
350,000 we have this enormous mismatch
and even chris christie was effective in
one of his otherwise painful look right
into the camera mode the government has
lied to you and they have stolen from
they told you that your Social Security
money is in a trust fund all that's in
that trust funds is a pile of io use for
money they spent on something else a
long time ago but as long as we're still
in the Donald Trump and Ben Carson phase
of the Republican primary season you can
bet that all candidates will be focused
on the real enemy no not the debt or
entitlements or even Hillary Clinton but
the damn liberal media the American
people don't trust the media how about
talking about the substitute issues
you